Your music app just played you a song you love, by a band you have never heard of.
Somewhere in a data center, two lists of numbers got compared,
and the comparison said: same taste.
So here is the question of the night.
How do you score a match between two lists of numbers?
Hold that question.
One answer to it runs half of modern machine learning.
Strip it down.
A taste is an arrow: each direction is a quality,
and the length is how hard the song leans that way.
Take one probe arrow and four candidate arrows.
Multiply them entry by entry and add.
That single sum is the score.
Before you drag anything, call it: which candidate ends up on top,
and does any score go negative?
Now turn the probe and watch the bars answer.
Point at a candidate and its score climbs.
Turn away and it dies.
So a big score means two songs are the same, right?
Watch again.
The bars moved while the candidates never moved at all.
The score reads agreement of direction, not sameness.
Look at what your hands just learned.
Point the probe along a candidate and the sum climbs.
Point it across and the sum dies to zero.
Point it against and the sum goes negative.
One multiply and add, and it behaves like a meter with agree,
ignore, and oppose on the dial.
So say it plainly: the dot product is a similarity meter.
Two lists of numbers go in.
One honest reading of alignment comes out.
And the reading tracks direction, because direction is all the sweep ever changed.
Time to close the loop.
Rebuild the meter from memory: two arrows go in,
so what two operations turn them into the score?
While you think, one detour worth naming.
Swap the songs for a job posting.
Score yourself against what the role wants: multiply the matched entries,
add them up, one number for the fit.
Different aisle, same meter.
The multiply-and-add never asked what the numbers meant,
and that is exactly why it travels.
Now the honest look, and guess before you watch.
Double c1's length exactly, leave its direction untouched, does the number double too?
It does, exactly.
Double one input, double the output: the meter is linear in each arrow you feed it.
That clean scaling is the crack.
Long songs would win on sheer loudness, and padded resumes would win on sheer length,
because size passes straight through.
For the walk home: what is the cheapest fix that keeps the direction and forgets the size,
now that you know size scales the score in lockstep?
Still up?
The menu below has three ways to keep going.